quienes aquí han tenido que lidiar con
yo estoy aburrida no hay nada que hacer
cuando vamos de vacaciones un lugar
donde no hay internet
bueno tengo dos hijas
marcela de 14 años y envidias de 13 años
y ese es mi día a día
ellas tienen el poder de convertir miami
en la mejor mamá del mundo cuando decido
compartir la data de mi celular
y en la peor cosa del mundo cuando yo
decido restringirle el uso
tengo el poder de crear la desesperación
masiva con solo decir nos vamos de fin
de semana y se queda el celular en la
casa eso es increíble en mi casa no es
sorpresa para nosotros que los niños
desde antes del año ya están expuestos a
todos estos medios digitales que sin
apenas hablar pueden localizar la
aplicación de youtube en una tableta y
buscar su vídeo favorito
de hecho les parecerá como
extraordinario que entre los seis vídeos
más vistos del mundo hay dos que son
destinados a niños de menos cinco años y
justos tienen más de siete millones de
visitas
pero no sólo eso sino que también uno de
los youtubers más famosos tiene apenas
siete años así que ya se imaginan
tenemos una generación de mini genios
niños que desde que nacen están
expuestos a aparatos electrónicos a
medios digitales que tienen todas las
respuestas que quieren en la palma de su
mano al momento que la necesitan pero
bueno yo no vine aquí para hablarles de
todos los beneficios que ofrece la
tecnología para la educación y
entretenimiento de nuestros hijos osea
por favor ya sólo sabemos yo vine aquí a
hablarles acerca de ese secreto
disfrazado de una adicción
buena y como eso está afectando la
movilidad de nuestros niños y sus
habilidades motoras como la espacialidad
como profesora de baile he tenido la
oportunidad de trabajar con niños de
este 4 a 12 años de edad
he visto su desarrollo motor a lo largo
de todo ese camino y he podido ver como
ellos seleccionan a diferentes estímulos
por extraño que parezca a medida que los
niños se acercan a la edad límite mayor
les es más difícil seguir comandos
sencillos como dame dos pasos a la
derecha o aguantar el equilibrio de todo
tu cuerpo y tu peso en la pierna
izquierda
pero lo que me llamó la atención fue
cuando tuve la oportunidad de hacerle
una coreografía con niños de 15-16 años
cuando realmente vi que había un déficit
muy grande en esas habilidades motoras
yo les pedí que levantaran su brazo
derecho se miraron ambas manos y cuando
reconocieron cuál era la derecha
entonces la pudieron subir eso me llamó
muchísimo la atención así que decidí
hacer un ejercicio con ellos los puse
todo en una fila por orden de tamaño y
le dije que volvieran a su posición
original luego con ocho tiempos
musicales uno dos tres les pedí que
caminaran hasta el lugar de la fila que
ya les había puesto para mi sorpresa eso
parecía como un mercado cuando todo es
tan especial y todo el mundo está
corriendo y pisando sé y empujándose
para llegar a su lugar en la fila el
tiempo se agotó y hubo algunos que ni
siquiera pudieron llegar a su lugar y
creanme ocho tiempos en el doble de lo
que necesitaban para llegar a su sitio
era claro que había una deficiencia en
su espacialidad
pero qué es la parcialidad que ya le
mencionaba ya varias veces hoy la
espacialidad es aquello que nos ayuda a
determinar dónde estamos en un lugar que
hay cerca de mí tanto objetos como
personas y qué situaciones están bien
están presentes también en ese entorno
junto con la espacialidad está la
propiocepción la propiocepción en la que
no ayuda a determinar la orientación de
nuestro cuerpo en un espacio es aquella
que nos dice oye tiene las piernas
cruzadas pero no tienes que verlo aunque
esté debajo de la mesa la propiocepción
nos ayuda
a poder caminar en una plataforma lisa y
luego cambiar a un piso con arenas y
nuestro cuerpo hará el ajuste esos
ajustes lo hace por las experiencias que
ya tenemos desde que somos niños
con la propiocepción podemos levantar un
galón de agua y luego un algodón y lo
vamos a hacer sin ningún problema porque
ya el cerebro te dice este land es es
este la necesidad de fuerza que necesita
para hacer tal o cual acción por eso
muchas veces no sé si le has pasado que
usted en una lata de una soda que está
abierta pero creen que está llena y la
levantan y se va hasta arriba bueno
básicamente eso es porque ya el cerebro
registrado que hay un peso específico
que debe tener esa lata que está llena
esa gracia esa a esa habilidad la
espacialidad en cambio la que no ayuda a
medir la distancia nos dice cómo las
cosas se ven cuando están cerca o cuando
están lejos cómo cambian de posición a
medida que nosotros nos movemos y nos
cambiamos de posición la espacialidad la
que nos permite hacer un mapa visual
de dónde están las cosas ubicadas en
nuestra casa o en nuestra habitación y
no tenemos que encender la luz para
andar entre ellas
pero qué pasa ambas habilidades se
desarrollan a través de las experiencias
motoras desde que el niño nace hasta que
tiene 17 años habilidades motoras como
bailar cómo practicar deporte cómo hacer
actividad física o cómo jugar pero qué
sucede que nuestros niños ya no tienen
tiempo ni de bailar ni de hacer
actividades físicas ni de salir a un
patio a jugar ya veces ni siquiera de
practicar un deporte
según un estudio publicado por la
asociación de investigación de medios
comunicación en europa ellos
determinaron que los niños de 6 a 7 años
pasan alrededor de 5 horas diarias en
las pantallas
pantallas vamos a referirnos a que son
videojuegos televisión es todo lo que
tengo una pantalla en frente y que los
de 12 a 13 años duran hasta 7 horas y
que ambos números
van incrementando paralelamente a medida
que el niño tiene más edad más alta la
exposición que tienen estas pantallas
así que si hacemos un cálculo rápido yo
le puse aquí si tenemos un niño de 6
años que dura 6 horas en el colegio
donde probablemente también está
trabajando en computadoras luego juega o
se entretiene viendo vídeos 65 horas al
día luego tiene aquí 9 horas para dormir
les quedan como 4 horas para comer
bañarse desayunar trasladarse de un
lugar a otro qué va a pasar con ese niño
en 5 años en 10 años
yo les voy a decir lo que va a pasar
vamos a tener niños en sobrepeso vamos a
tener niños diabéticos vamos a tener
niños hipertensos vamos a tener niños
con problemas de autoestima
vamos a tener muchos niños obesos
la organización mundial de la salud
en sus estudios publicados recientemente
dicen que el 80% de nuestro adolescente
no hace la suficiente actividad física
para mantenerse en salud
según ellos para el 2022 el índice de
niños obesos en el mundo se va a
multiplicar por 10
y que aquí en república dominicana el
60% de la población está en obesidad
antes la obesidad infantil se debía
mayormente a la alimentación la comida
chatarra la soja los dulces pero está
ahora el 50 por ciento de esa
responsabilidad lo tiene el sedentarismo
y te dirán bueno entonces qué vamos a
hacer
la verdad es que para mis hijas estar
conectadas es respirar no nos reímos
pero realmente hace la realidad que
tenemos ahora o sea para nuestros niños
mandaron en molló y de una manita es muy
fácil y yo no necesitan saber si es en
la mano derecho a la mano izquierda para
llamar a un amigo no tienen que
trasladarse porque lo pueden hacer con
un coach
o como un mensajito o con cualquier tipo
de otro medio que tienen porque tienen
10 millones de medio de comunicarse por
ahí
nuestros niños no van a tener que
arrugar un papel para echar la basura
porque con un clic la computadora lo va
a hacer para ellos van a ser increíbles
ingenieros arquitectos van a poder medir
el punto a al punto b con una facilidad
inmensa o sea de verdad de verdad la
tecnología va a ser que ellos sean
genios
pero van a ser niños torpes
no van a saber manejar
no van a poder diferenciar la derecha de
la izquierda
van a andar tocándose con todos los
muebles en la casa
no permitamos que aquello que viene a
darle un mundo de oportunidades que
aquellos que lo conectan con grandes
cosas en esta vida que le da tanto
conocimiento que le va a abrir las
puertas de la educación a un nivel que
nosotros no tuvimos sea lo mismo que lo
desconecte de toda la realidad del mundo
nosotros
no conocemos este problema
porque cuando crecimos
jugábamos en el patio de la casa pero
está en realidad de ahora
en cuanto a seis niños en una misma
habitación y ninguno se mira a la cara
y logrando el caso es que no me dejan
mentir las madres que están aquí que han
visto a sus hijos así en la habitación y
yo he entrado lo he dicho pero ustedes
tienen visita porque no estamos acá
estamos jugando
estamos conectados todos estamos jugando
el mismo tiempo pero no se ven no se
tocan
no saltan no corren no se mueven
no pasa nada
así es que hoy quiero compartirles mi
idea para cambiar esto
los niños aprenden más viendo
que escuchando
juguemos
bailemos practiquemos deporte
visitemos el parque
formemos rompecabezas
apelemos bloques
hagan manualidades con sus hijos motiven
no hacer manualidades con sus hijos yo
sé que quizás para adolescentes ya es
muy difícil pero tenemos una generación
de niños que están haciendo hoy que
nacieron hace dos años que van a ver un
mundo totalmente diferente al de
nosotros
traten de extender la exposición a los
equipos electrónicos a las pantallas lo
más que puedan
no le den una pantalla a un bebé de tres
meses seis meses cinco cinco meses no lo
sienten en una silla de comer y le den
un ipad para que esté tranquilo déjenlo
quédate que se caiga que se pegue que
toque a diferentes superficies
limite en el horario de uso de los
equipos electrónicos muy importante de
esas 5 horas de exposición debería ser
solamente una hora y media destinada al
entretenimiento y el resto del tiempo a
la educación las horas dedicadas para
hacer tareas y educarnos no son contadas
en esas horas de emprendimiento o sea
pongan un límite en las horas de
enfrente de entretenimiento
así es que nada quiero invitarles a que
todos ustedes desde su posición ayuden a
los niños de su comunidad a que hagan un
cambio a que aprovechen el regalo enorme
que nos da la tecnología para ser seres
con un intelecto por encima de todos los
demás para que aprovechen su
conocimiento pero que no dejen de ser
mejores humanos gracias